aujourd'hui on vous emmène à la
découverte de la quiz room de
Saint-Quentin en yeline le principe
blind test et quiz pour faire comme à la
télé et on va se défier Clara toutes les
deux on sera aussi avec d'autres
journalistes de la rédaction de tv78 on
sera avec Grégory canalet et Michel
elmidoro
ici vous allez répondre à des questions
pas de surprise jusque là mais vous
allez avoir des jokers pour vous aider à
gagner le meilleur c'est que vous
puissiez bloquer vos
[Rires]
adversaires allez c'est parti que le
meilleur
gagne bonjour tout le monde c'est bon je
suis là on va pouvoir commencer
vous faites des profils joueurs ici donc
c'est pour ça que votre expérience elle
est 100 % personnalisée en gros à chaque
fois que vous venez c'est jamais les
mêmes questions c'est des thèmes
différents parce que en fait ce sera en
fonction de votre âge et de vos centes
d'intérêt du sport loisirs vie
quotidienne
pas mal de choix dans combien d'états
des États-Unis pratique-t-on encore la
peine de
[Musique]
mort oh non ah ouice 27 j'ai hésité j'ai
hésité en plus pour vous aider à gagner
voilà on met en place des jokers donc
vous pourrez voler les points de vos
adversaires vous pouvez doubler les
vôtres à chaque question et vous pouvez
aussi bloquer aussi ces adversaires là
avant qu'il puisse répondre et ça c'est
fun wou merci non mais c'est pas
possible non mais mais c'est pas
possible j' était le plus fort c'est un
scandale tout le monde vol tout le monde
vol on fait du coup deux parties qui
durent chacune une demi-heure et du coup
c'est pour ça qu'on est à partir de 22 €
par personnes donc à partir de 7
personnes vous êtes à 22 € et entre 4 et
6 vous êtes à 25
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais il a 5
points
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est Michael Michel le chef le maestro
oui elle m'a bloqué là
ça y est on a terminé les deux parties
on s'est super bien amusé on a passé un
super moment vraiment bravo Clara pour
ta victoire merci merci ça avec plaisir
alors si vous aussi vous voulez tester
la quiz room à SaintQuentin en Eveline
vous pouvez venir de 4 à 18 joueurs et
vous retrouverez toutes les informations
nécessaires en bas de votre
[Musique]
écran